do you think all of that intense
training and everything contributed to
your heart attack in fact it saved my
life and it's really technically a heart
incident
although i would have been dead if
somebody hadn't immediately screamed and
gotten someone there to give me cpr cpr
saved my life when you do better call
saul and you're at a studio location
yeah they have a health expert yeah
there's there's offices right there and
our health officer who had so much work
to do rosa had to run the whole covet
protocol scenario which got us through
the whole season she's there in her
office working hard every day she also
had an aed in her car
because we had no those are
defibrillators yeah and
we didn't have any of those on the set
and uh so after about 12 minutes of cpr
she handed me over to
some of the other people who knew cpr
well and she ran to her car and got the
defibrillator and it took three
three uh attempts to get me um
to a rhythm which is actually a lot
howard i guess
i don't under i don't know any of this
stuff but i was told later that um
when the defibrillator doesn't work
once that's not good when it doesn't
work the second time
that's kind of
like forget it
but then they jacked it up a third time
and it got me back to a rhythm
and uh and they and so that was what
saved my life and then i had surgery in
the morning and they put the balloon
through and yeah yeah i mean right
through here you can't even see it
anymore and they went through and
knocked out these little
pieces of plaque that had
broken off and blocked my widow maker
but we were talking about nobody and one
of the things that saved me was i
learned how to work out and uh because i
was in good shape you kind of enlarge
some of the um
other veins around your heart if you
work out a lot
and i had done that
and as a result
i was told that um more blood was able
then to go to my heart during cpr
because these veins were just a little
bit bigger from a lot of uh a lot of
working out
and uh so that helped me but also
recovery wise i recovered much faster
than
i think a normal person who wasn't
exercising so much wood
because i my body was already in good
shape so
some lucky things happened
i i had trained and i did the movie
nobody and i was in good shape
but most of all
i was near my co-stars ray seahorn and
patrick fabian who rushed right to my
side and ray held my head and patrick
grabbed my hand and they were yelling at
me because i guess i turned gray like
right away
and i stopped breathing and
and they were just yelling and yelling
and those studios are so big
that the crew which were at the other
end you know initially thought i don't
know someone is laughing over there or
you know it took a few seconds maybe a
minute or two for someone to walk over
there
and see what was happening and then
everybody kicked into gear and we were
lucky to have a couple great people who
and by the way take cpr classes because
you can save lives with them
you